the queer eye Fab five oh man and they
are about to school everyone on the art
of lip-syncing at least they're gonna
try to and our lauren zima was
exclusively on set for the very
divalicious season five premiere of lip
sync battle let's talk about it you came
to represent the divas
tell me how you made these choices
behind the songs guys I think it was
just a tribute to Britney
[Music]
[Applause]
as in toxic aiding lip-synch circus
onstage as three of the queer eyes fat
five transformed into a triple dose of
Britney's most iconic looks
[Music]
Johnny and I needed an iconic duo who
was african-american and Caucasian and
we were like gaga I'm beyond that like
we need the Fab five to follow them all
on Instagram and I just knew in my heart
I was like they would be so incredible
and clearly they are all in et was
behind the scenes of the rehearsal which
channeled Beyonce's Coachella
performance give me one word to camera
of what you wanted to bring to your
performance what did you want
Dianna commitment boldness form idiocy
okay listen I'm already calling up like
et hosts versus qui so gonna depress the
show premieres Thursday on the paramount
Network
[Music]